Donald Trump held his final unhinged
extreme lunatic rally in front of a
crowd of sycophants last night in
Vandalia Ohio and there were rumors that
he was going to announce his 2024
candidacy Trump did make an announcement
of a further announcement and a lot of
people highly titillated by this take a
look at Trump's big announcement
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida Florida
so
by all reasonable assessments next
Tuesday Trump will be announcing that he
is running for the Republican
Presidential nomination in 2024. this
was a particularly disgusting rally the
energy was extra dangerous one of the
targets of trump in the last few days
has been Nancy Pelosi
and
um it is uh quite horrifying we will get
to that momentarily uh Donald Trump
insisting you know maybe he should be
given back the nuclear codes then it
sucks
nothing happened to him except a great
verdict he's got a great verdict we go
by that verdict the Sox verdict but no
he had it in his socks you know that
right and others took many many
documents they take him out of the White
House they took documents I'm the only
one that can't take anything
but maybe our country would be better
off if I actually had the nuclear codes
JD because our enemies would be afraid
unlike the way they are now if I had to
think about what he's saying he's saying
I am so unstable that I actually might
just on a whim nuke people that me
having the codes would be a good
deterrent
people forget he lost the nuclear coach
twice
how do you explain that to the military
I've lost the military codes what do you
he lost a military coach twice I didn't
they're coming after me because I'm
fighting for you that's yeah
um completely unhinged I mean this this
is a man at this point so disconnected
from reality and Sanity that it is hard
to believe Trump then going after Nancy
Pelosi of course Nancy Pelosi's husband
recently attacked by a right-wing nut in
their home
he had to have skull surgery and here's
Trump talking about her she Pelosi said
please animals they're human beings I
said no they're animals
of course I think she's an animal too
you want to know the truth what
they'll say oh what a horrible thing he
said about dancing she impeached me
twice for nothing
they'll say oh these people the fakers
back there they'll say what a horrible
thing he called Nancy Pelosi an animal
let me tell you what she does to this
country and what she did to the and the
turmoil and it was all I used the word
yesterday I shouldn't my great first
lady got very upset I said I will never
use the word [ __ ] again
but what she did to us
in this country and yet we got more done
as an Administration and a president
than just about any president in the
history of our country in four years
so continued attacks on Nancy Pelosi
extremely uh poor taste classless as
I've said before money cannot buy you
class now interestingly former Ted Cruz
staffer Amanda Carpenter tweeted last
night quote I haven't seen a trump
speech in a while but the way he spoke
last night so favorably of executing
drug dealers after a short two-hour or
less trial and then sending the bullet
they were shot with to their families
was jarring well what Amanda Carpenter
doesn't know
is that this has actually been part of
Trump's routine at every rally for the
last several months and Kevin McCarthy
was even asked about this on CNN he's
like no no we we kind of should be
changing the law to execute drug dealers
this is a sick and disgusting group of
people here's the clip that Amanda
Carpenter is referring to and again if
you haven't been paying attention to
these rallies you probably would be
horrified by this but Trump does this at
every rally and the crowd cheers the
world is horrified but the crowd cheers
I'm calling for the death penalty for
drug dealers and human traffickers which
will upon its passage reduce drug
distribution and reduce crime in our
country by a minimum of 75 percent on
the first day that this policy is
instituted and maybe I could ask JD to
lead it you will never lose an election
again if you did and I don't like to
bring this up it's a tough subject
nobody I don't know if the country is
ready for it I can tell you with
President XI in China I see him say
president you have 1.5 billion people do
you have a drug problem no no listen to
this problem listen to this how do you
do that I really sort of knew but I
didn't want to
he probably thought I was somewhat naive
he goes we have quick trial I said
what's a quick try I think I knew what
that was too that means they catch a
drug dealer they give them a quick trial
not a trial that takes
12 years
and 12 years of appeals 25 years later
and everyone's dead by the time they get
to the end of the no this is a trial
that takes approximately two hours this
is extraordinarily authoritarian this
this is you know Russia has a 99
conviction rate red flag authoritarian
nightmare
and if there
did and
the and the bullet and you know the
bullet I don't know if anybody wants to
know this it gets a little bit too
graphic but the bullet has said to their
families you know that right
you know that it's actually sent to
their families it's pretty tough stuff
there's no games so they have no drug
problem whatsoever he actually thought
it was a foolish question I said do you
have a drug problem absolutely not what
are you talking about of course now
let's insert a little bit of Sanity into
what is a completely insane situation
during this rant Trump always claims
every drug dealer
kills 500 Americans each drug dealer is
responsible directly for killing 500
Americans
that's just made up
um
I mean just just Google it look for the
information check out anything you want
to check if there is no evidence he's
grappled onto that fact that is not a
fact that claim and it is based in
nothing that's number one now number two
even for Trump's all of tough all of
Trump's tough talk about execute drug
dealers do a two-hour trial send the
bullet to their families even despite
all of that
Trump pardoned many drug dealers when he
was in office so even his own supposed
disdain and uh desperation for harsher
treatment of drug dealers Trump pardoned
many drug dealers when he was in office
so just another instance of hypocrisy
for sure uh last thing here and we're
not doing a ton of these clips today
we've got a lot of little things
Trump has started to refer to Trump
rallies as religious experiences and in
fact referred to the moment when it
started pouring at his Miami rally on
Sunday as such a religious experience
but you know the people it was actually
people have said today it was like a
religious experience the people the
music comes on and then boom we just got
it was like unbelievable I've never seen
anything like it right you know the
teleprompters one of them just crashed
and broke now remember
for years he criticized Barack Obama for
using a teleprompter and now Trump is
talking about forget about the fact that
he uses a teleprompter at every speech
he's talking about the fact that without
it it was really difficult to continue
giving a speech the other one was
useless because if you ever ride in your
car where you get a really heavy
rainstorm and try and see through
without the windshield wipers which by
the way
they planned it's called planned
obsolescence they can make a windshield
wiper that would last 100 years but they
make them only so they last exactly one
year then you have to buy a new one
which means they're smart Okay Trump
probably doesn't realize you just take a
paper towel to the windshield wiper and
then you know you get another year out
of it every time you do it but anyway
this is that's too pedestrian for Trump
let's let him keep doing but you ever do
that where you're driving and you can't
see well that's what I had with my
my remaining teleprompter so we had to
go and we had a great evening uh one of
the greatest rallies we've ever had and
it was caused by God sending us the
heaviest rain I've ever seen you know
what's funny about that and then we'll
move on some of you might remember when
Trump was inaugurated in January of 2017
he claimed that the rain stopped and the
sun came out and it was a sign from God
about how happy God was about Trump
being president now it was a lie it was
just rainy that day but most importantly
the point was God expresses his pleasure
by making it sunny
and now Trump is saying God expressed
his pleasure by sending rain to make it
like a religious experience that is
emblematic of right-wing thinking when a
happens it's because things are really
good
but when the opposite of a happens it's
because things are really good the
meaning of a and the opposite of a is
the same depending on what's convenient
at the time this guy is almost certainly
announcing next Tuesday that he's
running for president it is going to be
an insane two years it will be worse if
these people clean house tonight let's
hope we've all voted let's hope we
prevent them from doing it I want to
tell you about something I use every day
because it simplifies my life I don't
have hours to mathematically plan every
meal or take multiple different
supplements and vitamins to make sure
I'm getting exactly what I want to get
every single day and the solution is our
sponsor athletic greens product ag1 I've
been taking ag-1 for over a year it's
just great it's just one small scoop of
ag-1 in the morning I get 75 vitamins
minerals probiotic all from whole food
sources it's what I want it's no more
it's no less it's no extraneous stuff
making wild claims I drink it straight
with water because I like the taste you
can put it in a smoothie or juice or a
shake it's just simple ag1 is a
sustainable routine because it's just
one scoop in the morning takes one
minute once a day I know I'm covered in
getting what I want I can really be sure
that I am properly nourishing my body
with the things I'm trying to get that's
the most important part athletic greens
knows I'm a vitamin D guy I've talked
about in the winter I take vitamin D to
make up for the lack of sun exposure I
take that every day as well I've
mentioned it on the show and so athletic
greens is giving you a free year of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below